one of the most famous events in the
history of the USSR is its invasion of
Afghanistan in which much like their
opponents had done before the Soviets
attempted to use military means to prop
up an ideologically friendly government
however unlike say when the United
States fought in South Vietnam when the
USSR had previously propped up friendly
governments in Eastern Europe there were
no allies involved and in Afghanistan
the soviet-led military Alliance the
Warsaw Pact didn't get involved which
raises the question why why didn't the
Warsaw Pact also invade Afghanistan so
as you'll know the USSR created the
Warsaw Pact in 1955 as a response to the
creation of NATO and for the Soviet
Union it was a Cornerstone of its
defense policy throughout the Cold War
not only in a military sense but also in
a political one this was because it
allowed Soviet actions to be backed by
numerous other states on the
international stage this is why the USSR
made use of warsaw-packed troops to
occupy Czechoslovakia in 1968 when its
government wouldn't do as it was told so
when the USSR invaded Afghanistan at no
point was the Warsaw Pact consulted or
asked for its help and for the Soviets
the main reason for this was that the
alliance was seen only as defensive as
far as the Soviet military was concerned
the Warsaw Pact was a speed bump for
NATO and by taking troops from these
countries and deploying them to
Afghanistan this would weaken their
primary defense and would have
theoretically left an opening for an
attack another reason was that the USSR
wanted to prove that it could do it
alone many in the Soviet Army feared
that their International reputation was
diminished and so by being able to
deploy hundreds of thousands of troops
for a long period it would remind the
world that the USSR was still a
superpower and also it didn't care about
how the invasion looked internationally
unlike Czechoslovakia the USSR was happy
to look like it was doing it entirely
for its own purposes and that the rest
of the world could do nothing about it
another problem when it came to the
Warsaw Pact head into Kabul was that
their ability to help out was limited
the militaries of countries like Poland
and East Germany were designed around
holding off NATO until the USSR arrived
and thus those in charge didn't have the
know-how or ability to fight a
counter-insurgency furthermore the most
advanced equipment in the Warsaw Pact
belonged to the Soviet Union and so the
Warsaw Pact could only really provide
men something which the USSR simply
didn't need more of the final and most
important reason was that the USSR
likely couldn't have used the Warsaw
pack due to the ongoing stability issues
they were having most of the people in
these countries weren't exactly happy
with the presence of Soviet troops there
and many such as Hungary Poland East
Germany and Czechoslovakia had been
punished when the governments and people
weren't friendly enough to Moscow and
the populations in those countries
remembered thus forcing or trying to
convince the people of those Nations
that their soldiers should travel to a
country that they have almost zero
contact with and due to it what had
previously been done to them wasn't
likely an easy sell and would thus lead
to further anti-soviet sentiment and
these things combined meant that
bringing the Warsaw Pact to Afghanistan
was a no-go I hope you enjoyed this
episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James bizonette Kelly moneymaker
call show wolf Sky Chappelle kotoitska
Jerry lambdin Alex Schwinn Adam Stalter
Jordan Longley rod D Martin why in
hockey Marcus arsner Captain psydog
Marvin Castle Spencer Lightfoot Winston
caywood boogly Wiggly Daniel tobian
kamun Yoon Miss izet Gustav Swan Aaron
the white Anthony Beck
Coppertone spinning three plates she
went in words about books podcast and
Charles the first